former Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey has
backtracked on his former claim that
Elon Musk is the right person to be
running Twitter he recently explained
this on Blue Sky also known on Blue on
on Fox News as Bluesky I don't know why
but Janine Pirro called it Bluesky if
that's the right pronunciation I didn't
catch wind of that on Blue Sky Jack
Dorsey said he no longer believes that
Elon Musk should be running Twitter and
that he has not been the best Steward
for it this is obvious you know I
recently had a conversation with Lex
Friedman that's going to be released
anytime and one of the things I said
about Elon Musk is I don't really buy
into these Cults of Personality whether
it's Bernie or whoever I always am about
what are the positive ideas that this
person brings to the table nobody's
perfect nobody has only good ideas Elon
Musk did incredible things pushing
forward on electric vehicle and Battery
Technology 100 deserves credit for that
he also seems to have completely
destroyed Twitter